hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer
and i provide content for new and
aspiring software engineers
and today we're going to be talking
about reasons
to go to a coding bootcamp in 2021
now this is a follow-up to my previous
video
of reasons to not go to a coding
bootcamp in 2021
where i was brutally honest with things
so if you want to check that out check
that out and i'll link it above
but now to give you the whole picture
this is why
to go to boot camp in 2021 so let's get
to it so reason number one the first
reason you should go to coding bootcamp
specifically
in 2021 is because interest rates are at
a record
low right now now why am i talking about
interest rates
well coding boot camps are expensive
one of the reasons in my last video why
i said you shouldn't go
but if you need to take out a loan to
cover
you know the ten thousand twelve
thousand fifteen thousand twenty
thousand
cause to the boot camp well you're in
luck
because interest rates are very low and
so you'd be able to get a loan
for you know not much hassle and that is
not very you know expensive
and so of course things you know
contribute
to the rate you'll get such as your own
credit score
but in general if you have a good
credit score and you know is depending
on the length of the
loan and everything interest rates
really won't look too bad for you as
opposed
to other time periods reason number two
you should go to a coding bootcamp now
because
it is virtual now this
depending on who you are this could be
good this could be bad
for me it was oh so good because
i was able to go to a coding boot camp
that wasn't in the city
that i lived in if everything was
in person and all normal it would have
been very difficult
for me to commit to that lifestyle
because it would have required me to get
up at 8am
drive an hour down to the city the
coding bootcamp was in
spend the entire day and get back at
around
8pm if not later but because things were
virtual i was able to do everything from
the comfort of
my bed and when i say my bed i quite
literally mean my bed
i was one of the bad students who
wouldn't even get up
from my bed and go to a separate table
or
desk or anything i would people when
they you know when we were in classes
and everything they would see my
headboard
right behind me different strokes
different strokes it's okay
but it is so much easier for me
or it was so much easier for me to
commit to a boot camp because i didn't
need
to make that journey every single day
and so if that's the case for you that's
really a reason
why boot camp would be great now now
some of y'all may be thinking okay well
i could choose you know the online
version you know
instead of the in-person version because
the online version of coding bootcamp
for most coding bootcamps
is self-paced it's often designed for
people who
um you know have demanding jobs or you
know can't go to the city they're in
or prefer a more more autonomy over what
they do
day by day however i wanted an
in-person experience because i felt that
i'd be more
held accountable that way and i liked
being able to ask
life questions to my instructors and you
know really get those live
updates which you can't with which for
which
with my understanding i don't know i
don't know i never did the online
version
um but yeah it was less so with the
online
now this is confusing because we were in
a parallelogram
so what was online
and what was in person they were both i
i don't like to say they were both
online i say one was an online which was
you know the self-paced
more type experience and one was virtual
in person and so i chose the virtual in
person which would have
been the regular in person if we weren't
in this whole panera bed so just
something to think about you know
if you're in a city that it would
be hard for you to take that daily trip
or
your family situation is a way that it's
better for you to stay at home
rather than go somewhere and all of that
it's virtual right now so you know
that could be a very good thing if you
let it now the next reason to go to a
coding boot camp
is because you are the person who
prefers an actual learning
roadmap when it comes to learning new
skills
or you know transitioning into a certain
life you prefer having an
actual roadmap now i'm not saying you
prefer to have an actual roadmap
and you know teaching is the only way
you know you get that
but i'm saying if you are this is the
reason to go
to a coding bootcamp this was my
situation
i started out learning with codecademy
and
udemy courses however because i
am a person who needs to one be held
accountable by
some larger figure either a teacher or
an
administrator or anything like that and
because
i didn't know what i was doing i didn't
know that you know the next step to
learning javascript is to learn you know
if statements then after you learn if
statements you know you try
you know you learn try catch then you go
to ruby like i didn't know
what the sequence should be and so
because of that i
needed a teacher i needed somebody in
authority who created an actual
curriculum to guide me some people are
able to create their own curriculums
through you know codecademy and through
udemy and youtube tutorials and there
are just
so many different resources out there
for you to transition to software
engineering
without spending loads of money there
are and
please please please before this is an
asterisk before you decide to go to
coding bootcamp
please please please try out those
things first so you can really
understand
why you are going to a boot camp and
what you're really hoping to get out of
it because again that's so much money
y'all that's
that's so much money but if you are like
me who
did these three things and then got
stuck because
you didn't know what the next step is
but you also
aren't trying to you know get a whole
master's a whole
another bachelor's degree and all of
that go
to going to a coding boot camp may be
the right path
for you because again it's quick
relatively you know quick when we're
talking about whole career shifts as
quick
then yeah that would be a great reason
for you to go to a coding boot camp and
lastly the reason you should go to a
coding boot camp is because
depending on the boot camp in my boot
camp this was the case
you have the opportunity to get all of
your money
back if you don't get a job
after you finish your boot camp i don't
know
how many boot camps do this i went to
flat iron school and that was the case
for me and so for me
i was like you know what's there to lose
either i get a job
or i get a refund to me it was very low
risk
and so that could be a great way for you
to become a
software engineer through a coding
bootcamp because
it's 2021 and people are broke up in
here people are broke
people are struggling and
if we can get that assurance
that is great that would be great and so
again not all boot camps offer um
this you know clause if you design
if you decide to sign up with them but
i personally recommend looking for ones
that
do because then it just made the
decision much easier for me it made me
feel like i really wasn't
risking much now
this is you know like a whole other
asterisk
look into the things you need to do
to ensure that refund so
here's the thing so a boot camp says 100
money back if you don't get a job in
three months let's say
that is what they say when you read the
fine print this is the case for me when
you read the fine print of that
statement
you get a whole laundry list of things
that you must
do between you know finishing coding
bootcamp during coding bootcamp and up
to three months
after um completing your bootcamp you
need to be able to have
done all of these things and if you
haven't done all these things which
included
contact you know people on linkedin
three times a day
um write write two blog posts
a month um all of these different things
if you don't do
just one of them there goes a refund
there it goes so make sure that the
things when you read the fine print of
whatever boot camp that is stating these
things make sure that they're things
that really do seem actually
possible and plausible for you
for you specifically to do because yeah
if you're going on this path because you
feel like it's risk-free but then you
end up not getting the refund
and now you're unemployed for a year
and you still don't you know you don't
have a job you have this 15 000 in debt
and you know you're not getting this
refund then
that i'd say was not a great choice for
you and so make sure
you read that fine print and see exactly
what they list out
you that's the things you need to do in
order to get that refund
so but the reason they say these things
out is because
to them they say well you know what if
you do all of these things then you will
get a job
and so you know that's why we list those
things out so it's not like
a it's not bad but make sure for you
specifically it's something
that every single thing on that list
would be plausible for you so
there we have it everybody the reasons
you should go to
a coding bootcamp in 2021 but please
put any questions you have down below
and i'll try to answer them
either through the comments or through
making an actual video
and please don't forget to subscribe i'm
so happy every time i see
somebody subscribe and somebody
interacting in this community it makes
me very very happy
so please subscribe and choose to join
this community so i will talk to you all
later bye